alexandre benalla était dans le bus des
bleus lundi présent aussi lors de
l'entrée au panthéon de simone veil tour
à tour responsable de la sécurité de
plusieurs personnalités aujourd'hui
chargé de mission à l'elysée l'homme
était déjà visiblement connu pour ses
méthodes musclées laurence nomme
un déplacement officiel d' emmanuel
macron
alexandre benalla est tout près quelques
jours de vacances pour le président
entre tennis et vélo alexandre benalla
est toujours là et même il ya trois
jours le retour des bleus champions du
monde il est encore au coeur du
dispositif
c'est au parti socialiste qu'il débute
sa carrière dans les services de
sécurité auprès de martine aubry tout
d'abord on le voit ici à droite en noir
il a à peine 20 ans et suis la candidate
pendant toute la primaire
[Musique]
l'année d'après il est juste derrière
françois hollande pendant la campagne
présidentielle
puis c'est arnaud montebourg alors
ministre qu'il embauche comme chauffeur
première alerte je m'en suis séparé au
bout d'une semaine après une faute
professionnelle d'une première gravité
il avait provoqué un accident de voiture
en ma présence et voulait prendre la
fuite
cela ne l'empêchent pas quatre ans plus
tard d'être nommé responsable de la
sécurité du candidat macron mais son
comportement interpelle certains membres
de la campagne notamment le jour où il
fait un devis pour deux pistolets à
balles en caoutchouc
un flash ball et des boucliers
anti-émeutes demande jugée dangereuse
est refusé
autre alerte nous sommes à caen en 2017
lors d'un meeting alexandre benalla s'en
prend à un journaliste de public sénat
il le ceinture l'éloignent du candidat
avant de lui arracher son accréditation
coûte 100 méthodes musclées celui qui
est lieutenant colonel de la réserve
opérationnelle de la gendarmerie n'a pas
souhaité répondre à nos questions
[Musique]